how's it going breaths this is beautiful
[ __ ] out so I was gonna record a
video today but I just don't have the
strength or the energy to really do it
my buddy Ken was here a week ago and
that [ __ ] got me sick hey Ken [ __ ] you
so I've been sick for a week and I've
been trying to get the videos out anyway
and really forcing it to to work but
today I just feel like I can't be
bothered I just yeah so instead of
getting a half-assed shitty video you
get a half-assed shitty video but an
honest one isn't that right Edgar well
[ __ ] off then I realized I haven't taken
a day off for being sick since I started
making videos which is kind of weird I
really love doing the videos and I hate
to miss a day just cuz I'm not feeling
well this videos literally just me
feeling bad from sorry for myself like
oh no poor me literally I just want to
get back on my feet again I want to be
healthy again and I'm sick of being sick
you ever feel like that you still go to
schools I bet nine oh yeah I decided to
do an update blog instead again a lot of
people seem to be concerned about my
health lately because I seem skinnier
but I think it's just because I shave
the beard I I'm not doing cocaine at the
moment I also started working out when I
got my beard so when it once I shaved I
think I lost a little bit of weight and
that's why I looked like you can
actually see my cheekbones now which
wasn't I wasn't a thing before
I'm surprised as well that's another
reason I'm really fed up with being sick
is that I can't exercise what I
discovered that exercising is is so
important to me because it takes out so
much stress from from YouTube oh my god
I did it again you to be so hard it's
it's not I'm sure you noticed
I'm on the new set up the sound is
garbage I'm working on it thank you for
being patient a lot of comments are
saying wow your new office looks so cool
pewds there's nothing it's just the room
there's living to compliment I will do a
setup video once we're fully setup I
think that'll be really cool I want to
make this place a little bit more
personal like I spray-painted the last
place I want to have a personal touch on
when I on my videos and yes I still live
with Marcia Michael helps me out with
videos just like Brad does and I used to
space asthma as an office I don't
actually live here I still live with my
idea we're still together you can calm
the [ __ ] down
thank you very much ah I hate being sick
I used to love being sick what when did
this change I guess when you really love
what you do you that changes its
perspective on things yeah I don't
record in my house because of the same
reason I got kicked out of my other
office you never know what's gonna
happen and my videos are loud and
there's there's gonna be problems
British people are so [ __ ]
passive-aggressive it's weird
so far no landlord has been knocking on
the door outside so I think that's
pretty good I think that's a thing
that's a good sign I want to say thank
you for supporting the channel there's
really been an increase in the amount of
people watching which is really crazy to
me because I've thought this channel
peaked long ago it has but it's still
going up that to me is incredible
because you see past youtubers that gone
big fast they gunned down even faster
and for me to maintain an audience and
keep doing what I'm doing it really
means a lot to me and I really
appreciate that you guys are watching
and I think it's because the content has
improved and a lot of that I owe that to
Brad and my
who helps me out with the videos coming
up with ideas and I think that's really
good it's really fun for me to work with
other people that's Richard me to say
that content has improved when I'm
literally making the worst video ever
right now the Lay's is one at least it's
like in the last phase the sickness I
feel like I need another day then I'm
gonna be fine
so I'm gonna go take a nap thank you
guys so much for supporting me I really
appreciate it and I'm sorry for this
garbage eyes video and I'll see you both
tomorrow hopefully I'll be back on my
feet then and as always stay awesome
press wait is coming
so basically what happened was we were
shooting in a she